this question comes in from Stein call
Ovid
forgive me for saying the name
incorrectly I sometimes wondered whether
I should write TV series in addition to
features but so far it seems to me that
stories that the stories I want to tell
are better told through films can mr.
Russell give an example of why a story
would be better told as a TV series well
if you love movies and so many people do
and I know that a lot of people who grew
up loving movies they're kind of
appalled that television has taken over
think of it this way you can tell any
movie as a TV miniseries you can take
the movie that you've been writing for
the last four or five years and you can
turn it into a television miniseries
more easily than you can turn it into a
TV series so think of it that way now I
spent several years learning genres of
movies mystery thriller crime thriller
horror all of these genres I've sort of
mastered the understanding the deep
understanding of each one of those
genres and every one of those John Rose
is very different and they all have
these cool tools that I learned to help
movie people well guess what turns out
when I turn my attention to television
all the rules of movie thrillers apply
to the crime drama that I'm selling as a
serial right now ray Donovan meets true
detective all of those cool structural
tools that work in seven that work in
all these classic movies turns out those
secrets transfer right over to
television so just you know that
everything you've learned about movies
works in TV but the easiest transition
is to move take your movie idea and turn
it into a miniseries why well for some
of the reasons we talked about earlier
which is mainly many see
are like long movies because the
characters have an arc they start with a
wound and they eventually heal or not so
if you're writing movies and you love
movies make the transition to television
by writing a miniseries where you can
simply stretch your idea into a longer
form forget the structure so much but
those cool tools which by the way I have
on my website Peter Russell script
doctor calm I go each genre of movies
has a set of hidden structures and tools
in it just take those in structures and
tools and apply them to your television
show in the same genre writing a comedy
apply the movie comedic rules to your
sitcom
writing a romantic comedy same thing
love story same thing and venture
romance same thing write a miniseries
it's a bridge form it'll help you learn
why television has two big differences
with movies one is that the characters
don't really change in television and
the other one is you can tell more than
you can in a movie where you want to
show everything so there's just more
dialogue but those are the two big
differences everything else can be the
same especially in a miniseries it's a
great bridge for you to learn this new
structure and you'll just have a better
chance of getting your story bought I
didn't say great chance I said better
chance because I think we're up to five
hundred and fifty scripted television
shows now in the u.s. there are a few
years ago there were 200 so and I I
believe that's gonna simply continue I
think in 10 years television is going to
be five times as big as it is right now
so if you want your work to sell learn
the new forms by bridging your way to TV
through using your movie as a miniseries
we're miniseries in fashion so to speak
previously I think we're the seventies I
know there were big miniseries in the
seventies like The Thorn Birds there was
another show called Shogun so these were
these were big event television so
they'd be on one night for three or four
nights five nights sometimes but then
there was a long period when they
weren't fashionable but they've gotten
very fashionable again you know Ryan
Murphy all these guys who write these
fantastic shows you know the OJ Simpson
trial the trust which is a great when
the Danny Boyle just did about the Getty
family brilliant miniseries and the
assassination of Gianni Versace they are
I think where a lot of movie makers are
going in television because it's a more
commodious form it's the easiest a way
to transition from film to television so
yeah and I think the miniseries also is
kind of satisfies our desire for seeing
a movie which is I want to see somebody
change I want to see a complete story
right when you're watching animal
kingdom
okay well Ellen barkins still gonna be a
poisonous okay well let's have
some popcorn at some point if you want
to sort of see what's gonna happen
right can can we have some resolution
can we actually resolve something in our
lives that's what great movies have
always done for us so I think that
instinct to be have a complete story is
why miniseries have become so much more
popular they're sort of replacing what
movies used to give us which is that
sense of a complete story ah we're done
Ellen barkins dead yay two of the kids
got help
they've got therapy right thank God we
can have dinner now right as opposed to
oh god she's still in jail is she still
in torment
right she's still wearing those awful
black contacts yes she is
she still looks like death right in a
movie she would have moved on you'd
probably be dead or she'd be okay but
yeah that's why miniseries I think
they're so popular so you said in the
70s they were popular can you see any
parallels between now and that time do
you think there's there's something in
audiences that is yeah III think that um
we are we love long-form entertainment
and we like that's I think what you
binge series - I think entertainment is
becoming like the Russian novel why
don't we might have the 19th century is
not so pretentious but the Russian novel
Tolstoy got longer and longer and bigger
and bigger and bigger bigger right in
the night and their children there were
a thousand pages 1,500 pages right
that's the sign of the maturity of an
art form right
that's when art form gets its best when
it gets big when it gets long I think
we're in in that kind of Suzy hates me
saying a golden age but I think we are
in a golden age of entertainment because
the stories are getting so much longer
and look you can tell everybody is
neither a good guy in ER a bad guy
everybody's got a combination of traits
in them right so a movie can't really
show you that there's not enough time
you're either good or you're bad
television and the longer form can show
both the good and the bad inside of all
of us it's a more sophisticated model of
human behavior I think we're just
getting to be more sophisticated as
people to know that people's stories are
complex
I'm not all good I'm not all evil I'm
mostly evil but there's some good in me
but that's the mix and so longer form
art can give us a camor complete picture
of our humanities about
you